شرطان اساسيان يجب توفرهما قبل ساعه الصفر
التي ستؤذن بانطلاق العمليه الاوكرانيه
المضاده المرتقبه تحسن الطقس واختفاء
الاوحال التي تعرقل تقدم الاليات والمشاه
واسئله جوهريه عما هو ات فمتى يمكن توقع
الهجوم المضاد
التقديرات تشير الى موعدين محتملين الاول
منتصف الشهر الحالي بحسب تلميحات وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني الاكسير
مقابل تلميح رئيس الوزراء
لان العمليه ستنطلق صيف العام الجاري فمن
اين قد تطلق اوكرانيا هجومها المضاد
يمتد خط المواجهات بين الجانبين مسافه
تتجاوز 1000 كيلومتر مؤشرات ميدانيه لا
تستبعد الانطلاق من الجبهه الجنوبيه
والشرقيه وسيحاول الطرفان الامساك او
الابقاء على مدن استراتيجيه
التي تضم واحده من اكبر القواعد العسكريه
في مقاطعات
التي تضم محطه
النوويه مدينه وميناء برديانسك على
السواحل الشماليه لبحر ازوف فيزا بوروجيا
والميناء على بحر ازوف خيرسون التي بدات
روسيا باخلائها من المدنيين الهجوم المضاد
يمكن ان يشمل ايضا شبه جزيره القرم ذات
الدلاله السياسيه والمعنويه يحمل شبه
الجزيره اهميه للجانبين بالنسبه لموسكو
القرمو هي اولى المناطق التي اقتطعتها عام
عمقا حيويا واستراتيجيا ببسط مزيد من
النفوذ عند شواطئ البحر الاسود
ولكياز تقدم استعاده القرم دفعا معنويا
كبيرا لانها تقاتل الاستعاده حدودها عن
واحد وتسعين وهل يمكن الاكياس ان تشن
هجومها المضاد دون سلاح الطيران تؤكد
اوكرانيا على حاجتها لطائرات الجيل الجديد
خاصه اف 16 القادره على اعتراض صواريخ
وطائرات متطوره لكن استخدام هذه الطائرات
سيحتاج تدريبا طويلا الامد ولكن خبراء
يرون غير ذلك انطلاقا من تجربه اوكرانيا
السابقه في هجومها المضاد على خرسون
وخاركيف سيعتمد الهجوم المضاد على تشكيلات
بريه كالويه الدبابات والمدرعات والنظم
المدفعيه التي تحميها انظمه الدفاع الجوي
[موسيقى]